Here again is a remove html markup program.
Here's the input which normally passes.
If I click on run, what I get is just a single quote.
That is, the opening tag was probably stripped,
and of course, the assertion didn't fire.
I am now setting up a trace function,
which specifically monitors for the moment.
The loop head here in line 8 is hit for the second time.
That's when I'm setting the quote variable to true
as found in the failing run.
So the question is whether by setting the quote variable
to the value found in the in the failing run at this moment,
we can already turn the previously passing run into failing run.
We figure this out by clicking on run.
As you can see, simply by setting the quote variable to true,
we now have triggered the assertion.
What this means is that simply setting the quote variable to true
is sufficient to make the passing run now fail.
We thus have identified quote as a cause for the failure.